avanza muy lentamente y trump pues sigue
adelante con su iniciativa de demandar a
los estados que recientemente le están
dando la victoria al presidente elector
yo bailé nevada arizona georgia
pensilvania michigan son los focos de
acciones legales del presidente trampa
acciones legales que como lo han dicho
ya varios medios de comunicación no
tienen fundamento uno de los que se ha
sumado a esta retórica de negar todavía
los resultados electorales fue maicon
feo el secretario de estado quien dijo
que la transición se va a dar
fluidamente pero fluidamente a un
segundo mandato de donald trump cuando
se terminen de contar los votos legales
una estrategia que según muchos pues le
va a favorecer al presidente de trump
porque va a seguir manteniendo ese apoyo
popular ya cuando llegue el 20 de enero
que sea y se concrete la transición
desde el poder
cristóbal hoy hubo dos anuncios
electorales el estado de georgia informó
que hará un recuento manual de todos los
votos emitidos en las presidenciales
a la estrecha ventaja entre los
candidatos con el 99 por ciento
escrutado el demócrata lidera el conteo
por 14 mil 112 votos por encima del
presidente de donald trump el secretario
de estado de georgia espera terminar el
conteo para el 20 de noviembre fecha
límite para certificar los resultados
hoy trump anotó además los 3 votos en el
colegio electoral que otorga el estado
de alaska
cristóbal que escenarios abre en estos
anuncios es que la presión de trompe
empieza a tener efecto si georgia fuera
finalmente para los republicanos como
modifica el panorama electoral tanto en
las presidenciales como en el senado
no lo modifica mucho en las
presidenciales el panorama electoral
teniendo en cuenta que pensilvania pues
sigue siendo del partido demócrata de
joe biden y pues pensilvania le da ese
margen de 270 votos superior a los
demócratas para quedarse con las
presidenciales usted lo mencionaba bien
con este en este momento pues ya donald
trump llega a los 217 votos electorales
con los 3 que le otorgó alaska y lo
bailen se mantiene en 290 votos según lo
dice la agencia ap pero georgia sigue
siendo el centro del foco de la atención
sobre todo porque el 5 de enero se va a
definir la carrera por el senado dos
candidatos republicanos pues van a tener
que defender en una carrera propia
contra sus contrincantes demócratas el 5
de enero si pues siguen en el senado y
aseguran la mayoría republicana en el
legislativo o si los demócratas aseguran
y pues logran ese cambio de mayoría en
el legislativo ese 5 de enero
y es importante porque pues lo que están
diciendo muchos analistas es que los
republicanos todavía no reconocen la
victoria del presidente electo joe biden
porque están tratando de asegurar que
los simpatizantes de trump en georgia
voten por los candidatos al senado de
ese estado y así poder asegurar la
mayoría del legislativo y ya después
entonces puedan entrar a reconocer el
presidente electo pero es un juego
político que se está jugando en georgia
que en las presidenciales no cambia
mucho pero que en la carrera al senado
si puede ser definitivo para el partido
republicano bien cristóbal vázquez
muchas gracias por tu reporte desde
washington nuestro corresponsal en la
capital estadounidense